it's interesting you know in in this
world a lot everyone wants to know
your business and what you're doing and
um
it's i think it's it's very interesting
when you go through things i think
initially it really bothered me
oh my god ellen how are you so many
beautiful girls at harvard
experienced girls sorry about you and
noah
we didn't break up though in the
beginning of this movie
everyone at elle's school assumes that
noah and elle have broken up there's a
lot of gossip and a lot of
scrutiny around their relationship for
both of you guys
dating and in hollywood how is that to
handle
uh so i've um i've had a pretty good
dating experience
um i'm engaged so it like all worked out
congratulations it was actually long
distance too so
um i am living proof
that a different zip code doesn't
actually mean
uh that it automatically ends you know
um
it's it's tough to do a long distance
relationship
but i think that once you can like
overcome those hardships
and actually come together in a
relationship into like
proximity uh then like
you can kind of make it through anything
yeah
that's a good story though happy endings
are nice yeah no kidding
um it's interesting you know in in this
world a lot everyone wants to know
your business and what you're doing and
um
it's i think it's it's very interesting
when you go through things
and um people feel like they are like
kind of owed an explanation
but i understand i understand um so for
me
i've you know publicly gone through some
things privately gone through some
things it's all about
finding your balance finding you know
what makes you comfortable
and um it can be it can be brutal but
you know also happy endings do come
to those who are you know patient
yes i love that oh i'm asking you to
trust me
at the very beginning um elle is still
obviously in high school senior in high
school and everyone's kind of
analyzing did they break up are they
still together
for you and kind of navigating hollywood
how is it when people
i guess kind of scrutinize or pay so
much attention to things like that and
how
how do you handle that sure i think
initially it really bothered me
just even the fact that somebody would
could be someone that you don't know
knows your name is quite like
disembodying um
but then eventually i think i just for
me personally i'm just
it's got nothing to do with me you know
it's like imagine
the store around the corner from where
you are now and whatever
people are talking about it's not your
business it's kind of how it feels it's
like
unfortunately just has my name involved
in it but it just it literally has
nothing to do with me it just doesn't
affect
the trajectory of my life so i just kind
of
ignore it you know no that's that's a
good way to handle it
you ask yourself if it's worth changing
all of your plans for him
i love this scene i love this girl
there's a lot of talk in this movie
about
a five-year plan for you and looking at
your
career and your life where where do you
see yourself in five years
in five years i'd love to be you know
right right where i am now
um you know in australia and
happy and with my family around at the
beach you know and working
you know hopefully in five years there's
no
awful virus floating around and the
world is a little bit healthier and
happier that would be beautiful you know
yeah i mean amen to that you celebrated
a birthday recently
yeah how'd you celebrate did you get any
cool gifts from any co-stars
did i got awesome gifts from my family
my sister made this this giant frame
of a heath ledger portrait out of dark
like dye like dice so the different
numbers of the dice black and white dice
make
the different colors so the whole thing
is a grit and it's a portrait of him
and then my mom got me a wooden a wooden
surfboard which is
amazing that's awesome as soon as school
ended noah and i spent the whole
summer together and then exactly 27 days
ago
my heart flew off to harvard are noah
and l
end game in your mind i don't know
i mean you know just like elle says in
the trailer she always thought they were
but things change things happen do you
think you know we're meant to be
together
we always thought we were i don't know
exactly where their story will take them
but um i i am so excited that we get to
see ellen noah in this movie
i think noah and elle are
iconic and i think that uh they you know
it's exciting for fans to be able to see
them
again do you think that ellen noah
our end game
yeah yeah why not i think so all right
just want to make sure you've given it
some forethought i know over the years
you've lost some brain cells i wouldn't
want you to say
something you might regret it do we have
update yet on euphoria season two do we
know when that goes back into production
no nothing you know everyone's still
arming and ironing because america is in
such
dire straits so um like i said hopefully
hopefully soon you know i would love to
go back to work
[Music]